In the previous lessons we worked with polynomial expressions. The variables had
non negative integer exponents. And our expressions could contain any number of
terms. We learned how to add, subtract, multiply and even divide these
polynomials. In the upcoming lessons, we'll make use of our new factoring and
look at performing these same operations for rational expressions. A rational
expression is a ratio of two polynomials. It is a fraction in which the
numerator and the denominator are both polynomials, 1 over x is an example of a
rational expression, since 1 is a mynomial and x is also a mynomial. The second
example contains the polynomial x plus 2 in the numerator, and 3x minus 1 in the
denominator. So this is also a rational expression. And this course will prepare
you to handle any sort of polynomial or rational expression. You'll be able to
add, subtract, multiply and even divide these rational expressions by the end of
this unit.